when you were culture secretary
did you ever consider privatizing
channel 4
um i didn't
and i'm not in favor of it because i
think that as it stands channel 4
provides competition to the bbc
on what's called public service
broadcasting the kinds of programs that
are not commercially viable and i think
it'd be a shame to lose that
why do you think the government's
considering it is it about the money and
the billion pounds that could be used
elsewhere
i don't know um and i you know i look
i'm not against privatization in in
other contexts but what i'm in favor of
is is competition
and i think that we have very high
standard of broadcasting in this country
because we have competition not just in
the the very popular
uh soap operas and
box sets and and series that uh
are going to be commercially very
successful but we also have competition
in other areas like news and
documentaries
which are not likely to be commercially
viable and that's i think it's really
important to maintain that competition
and i do think channel 4 is part of that
ecosystem